let me say this
dave you have a platoon
in your platoon there's a two different
let's call them clicks
and they have two different ideas of
what you should be focused on and how
you should operate
and what you do is you sort of negotiate
a piece between these two clicks and you
sort of compromise and you figure out
hey like we'll do a little bit of this
click a little bit of that click and you
kind of you kind of bring these forces
to a compromise
you get them working together you get
them to like take these things that they
could be arguing about you you give one
here and give the other side one here
and so you end up with a team that
although they're not perfectly in sync
they're at least sort of
working together
my platoon i have two clicks
and what i do is i get mad at them
because they don't get along
and then i agree with one of the clicks
actually a little bit more and so i give
them favoritism and now we end up with
this you know head butting
who who's got a better platoon
right so
if you think about this in a large
strategic view
and you look at a place called the
united states of america right now
and you look at how miraculously or
strangely we've become super divisive
about all kinds of things to the point
where we are banging against each
other's heads
and we don't get along
and we've got people that sit so far
apart in their beliefs not only do they
sit so far apart in their beliefs they
can't find common ground on anything
on anything
and we've got
known
known actors in the world
[Music]
that make moves
to increase the division between the
sides of people that we have in america
and the people in america don't even
recognize that all of this fighting
is making our platoon weak
it's very interesting isn't it
it's very interesting that we know
that there are actors that are cr there
are state actors that are creating
divisiveness in our own country and yet
instead of saying hey you know what
actually we shouldn't argue about that
stuff hey you know what dave you got
your opinion on that i got my opinion
but you know what there's a bunch of
stuff we agree on let's focus on that
okay you know what that makes sense we
can go execute the mission now
instead no you know what dave you don't
agree with me on this we'll screw you i
don't even want to work with you
now we can't operate we can't get
anything done
so obvious
yeah it's so obvious it's hard to look
at too because not only are you going to
disagree with me you can actively
actively sabotage my efforts 100 and and
the hardest part about that is that the
reality is we are on the same team
those two
those two platoons in your task unit
they're on the same
team
they're very disturbing
i've been trying i've got to think a way
to articulate that a little bit more
clearly
and
and present it in a way that people can
see it but it's very difficult because
when you present it if i present it to
the platoon and say hey guys i think it
looks like we're we're actually
looks like
we're actually not uh helping here we're
not moving this thing forward
you know what one side says oh so you're
trying to take their side are you yeah
that's exactly what happens that's and
that's the point i was thinking when you
said that when you you know you you were
sort of over like i show a little bias
towards this one team
which is all the other side needs to go
oh
i see what side you're on oh yeah i see
what you're i don't trust you're one of
them yeah i see what you're getting at
so i've got to think of a way to
articulate this properly to people
because right now
but we don't understand it as americans
we are in this sort of trap where
there's a total lack of coordination
between the different sides yeah our
government can't even get anything done
they're they're they're they're losers
they're just not not making any progress
and all they're doing is fighting with
each other and not realizing that while
we're fighting each other
number one there's other state actors
that are that are
feeding this fight
and while they're while they're feeding
our fight and we're having these in
fights guess what these other state
actors are doing
growing their economy
unifying their people
[Music]
growing their military strength
growing the will of their people
and we are being divided
i'll think of a way to try and
communicate this so people will
hopefully start to understand it
i haven't done a good job thus far